let's see if we can understand the
structure of a hedge fund a little bit
and also how the management and the
performance fees work out so most hedge
funds the funds themselves are set up as
limited partnerships so this is the
hedge fund that pete set up we'll call
it pete capital fund one he's maybe in
the future going to start fund two and
fund three and all of the rest and he's
able to raise a hundred million dollars
ten percent of that hundred million
dollars or ten million of it is coming
from him or i guess to be more exact
it's coming from pete capital management
llc limited liability company which he
starts off as the general partner of
this fund and just it might be a little
bit confusing but this is one company
this is another company over here this
company is going to manage the assets of
that company and in return it will be
able to get management fees and it will
be able to get performance fees and
we'll talk about that in a second and
probably pete owns this entire company
but he might have a couple of employees
probably four or five now the way it
works with the limited partnership is
they don't call it necessarily shares
but it's essentially the same thing
someone who out of this hundred million
contributed 30 million would get 30
percent in limited partner interest
someone who contributed 10
would get 10 million in limited partner
interest so let's just say that he does
really good over the next year that he's
able to on a gross basis before we take
out his management fee or anything else
grow the fund by 20 million dollars so
roughly on a gross basis 20 but this is
this is net of you know the trading fees
and all of the stuff that he has to pay
the broker and and all of that type of
thing
to understand kind of what goes to peat
capital management that pete can use to
pay himself and his handful of employees
first he gets the management fee and the
management fee will be on the average
net asset value and i'm going to do it a
little bit back of the envelope right
over here it's normally done on a
monthly basis but i don't want to go
into all of the accounting but if he did
this fairly linearly or if he does this
fairly consistently the average net
asset value over the year would be about
110 million dollars
so average would be approximately 110
million dollars and so he'll get about
two percent of that we're assuming he
gets a two percent management fee and 20
performance fee or 20
carried interest it's sometimes called
so if the average net asset value is 110
million you multiply that times two
percent and then that means that he's
going to get 2.2
2.2 million dollars in management fee
and this is for his salary his employee
salary to pay the rent to i know get
some fancy computers whatever it might
be this is kind of viewed as the cost
just to manage the fund
so we need to subtract that from the
total amount in the fund because that's
going to the management company so
instead of 120 million over here we're
going to have what is that 117
117 million point eight
117.8 million and then we'll have to
calculate how much he gets in a
performance fee so in this situation net
of his management fee we have a 17.8
million dollar gain so let me write that
over here we have 17.8
million in
profits
the way that we've set up the
performance fee or the carried interest
is that pete gets 20 percent of it or
more particular the general partner the
pete pete capital management llc the
partner that is controlling that is
managing this fund will get twenty
percent so let's multiply that times
twenty percent and what does that give
us that gives us
three point five six million
so three point five
six million will also
will also go to peat capital management
so not bad in this year he made a little
almost six million dollars and that's
probably going to go to him and you know
probably four or five employees so it
can if someone performs well it can be a
very uh profitable
business and just to make it clear how
the mechanics work here is that these
these funds tend to be open end funds
like open end mutual funds will not like
them they have to be private they can't
they can only take money from accredited
investors they can't market themselves
they don't have to register with the sec
but when i say that they are they can be
open-ended it means that at any point
well not at any point usually this is
restricted at certain points in time the
investors are allowed to redeem or kind
of add investments to what's going on in
the fund so let's say after at the end
of the year so instead of 117.8 we're
gonna have to subtract 3.56 from that
for peak capital management so what's
left in the fund is going to be and he
could leave it in there to reinvest but
that would just increase his share but
let's say pete capital management takes
it out so we'll be left with
let's see we have 100
minus
minus 3.56 right minus 3.56
it gives us 114.24
so over here what's left in the fund is
114.24
and let's say this period investors are
allowed to redeem their interest and
let's say this guy right over here this
guy with a 30 interest he says you know
what that's that was a pretty good year
i want to take 10 percent of my interest
out so instead of having a 30 interest
he wants to have a 10 interest so what
happens is so instead of a 30 this is
now a 20 interest he'll take 10 out so
he'll take 10 of
114.24 so he's going to take out that's
essentially going to be
we just have to move the decimal place
one over so he's going to take out
11.424
million that's this guy right over here
he's going to take out
11.424 million and then the fund will
decrease by that amount so he can at
these specific periods people can redeem
usually it's at the end of the month the
end of the quarter or the end of the
year and so then the fund will be left
with what's 100 let me take the
calculator out again
the fund will now be left with
114.24
minus 11.4
which is going to be 102.816
102.816 and at the same time other
people might say hey gee that was a
pretty good return i'm going to now
contribute to the fund so either way
it's not like it's a closed end fund
where just at the beginning people can
commit their capital and they can't take
it out until the end of the fund or they
can't
add more
during the life of most hedge funds at
specific periods people are allowed to
redeem their funds or they're allowed to
add more funds